euromaxx highlights and here's your host
colleen hempstead hi there anowar
welcome to our highlights edition coming
to you straight from brandenburg gate
here in the heart melantha and here's a
look at what's on the agenda for today
culture mix we visit the city of
Zaragoza in northeastern Spain movie
madness we get a glimpse of how work and
fun merge at the Berlin Film Festival
and winter attraction we take to the ice
on Europe's largest natural skating rink
all the scorpions are one of Germany's
most successful rock bands and as of
this year they've even added the
qualifier oldest because they've been at
it for an incredible 50 years well this
tune is one of their signature hits
listen there that is wind of change
which became synonymous with the process
of German unification after the fall of
the Berlin Wall and the dramatic scenes
that played out right here behind me at
brandenburg gate while their early
decision to sing in English won them a
huge international following over the
years and now a brand-new documentary
masterminded by Deutsche Welle tells
their story
the scorpions are giants of rock
better late than never now the first
big-screen documentary about the
Scorpions will come to the theaters now
Saturday the film premiered in Vernon
the hard rock veterans might have seen
it all up to harper center in the
business but this was a night to
remember for them to
does this go into your oven because this
is a completely new experience for us
all since seeing the ban on the big
screen together with moviegoers and
during the Berlin Film Festival it's a
very special night on a moment the film
crew spent three years alongside the
most successful German rock outfit ever
the Hanover group boasts record sales of
over 100 million and a string of hits
such as still loving you
the flan provides footage of spectacular
live shows and behind-the-scenes action
it also takes viewers back to the band's
formation in 1965 and covers their
progression to mega stardom in the 1970s
and 80s
for the musicians themselves revisiting
their own past is often a revelation
among the highlights this legendary 1983
appearance at a festival in California
in cough then you always imagined you
stayed the same persons so a film that
delves into the past and fees like
having a mirror held up on front of you
be good and fuller to it filming began
in 2011 during the tour the band had
said would be their last the film who
took to the road with them across the
u.s. France
and Thailand then there was the
challenge of assembling the material
into a 97 minute film egg phyla of
course I wanted to show cornerstones of
their career which impressed me the most
but above all it was about personal and
entertaining moments this was meant to
be a farewell tour but the rezoning
response had all those shows around the
world persuaded the band to show those
retirement plans for a while
via hamas mittens affair virtua this
farewell tour Turkish out of our comfort
teen eros cords need masks antibes
usually don't even notice that you're
getting stale babe your vibe but then
suddenly you're in an airport and fans
are swarming around you with flowers and
tears in their eyes we realized how much
we meant to them must be tightened VI
hd's and friends the head of deutsche
welle culture and society department
while fisher first had the idea to
produce a definitive documentary about
the band back in 2008 we hadn't 4949
gauze and film from the outset we wanted
it to be an ambitious production the big
scope is always going to be more
exciting for the filmmakers as well as
the viewers it makes it more compelling
more interesting and ultimately means
that it will reach a wider audience
other ambitious productions masterminded
by deutsche welle scholar and society
department include the beethoven project
the colon ring vogner in buenos aires
and in 2013 the highest level starring
pianist lang lang and conductors sir
simon rattle do dr. a leak under such
productions allow Deutsche Welle to show
what it's capable of to demonstrate its
creative potential that's very important
to us at the after-show party the band
the production crew and the audience
celebrate their successful cooperation
mr Turner finger von it's a fantastic
film and we're really thrilled with all
the positive feedback about on ours on
say a positive as he didn't work on
after the huge success of the world
premiere in Berlin the documentary will
hit German cinema screens in late March
and is also slated for international
release and needless to say forever and
a day will also be shown of Deutsche
Welle
full time now for a virtual travel into
the interlude as we head to Zaragoza in
northeastern Spain now that is Spain's
fifth largest city and home to some
700,000 people it's colorful past has
made for a fantastic mix of architecture
that is well worth seeing and we also
found out why a number of important
European firsts happened right here the
statue of King Alfonso the first of
Aragon reigns high above the city of
Zaragoza dubbed the warrior alphonse
reclaimed the city from the Moors 900
years ago and he made it the new capital
of his Christian Kingdom the baroque
basilica del pilar by the river Ebro is
one of Zaragoza same asst landmarks and
a popular pilgrimage site local resident
Carlos highness arcta is an expert on
the city's heritage in das momentos de
la storia saragosa aragon went through
two periods of prosperity davida last
race to first in the 11th century when
the Moorish Jewish and Christian
cultures intermingled and influenced
each other and then in the 16th century
small boats were used on the arrow to
ship goods from the Mediterranean to the
north of Spain norte de espana
the various architectural styles reflect
the city's colorful past the AL hoffa
ria palace dates back to the 11th
century and was a symbol of moorish
supremacy it was built in the style of
Arabian desert palaces and served as a
model for the Alhambra in Granada the
Mo's brought paper towel andaluz the
name they gave to Spain before that
paper didn't exist in Europe they also
introduced algebra that's why we use
Arabic numerals and the concept of zero
is something the Arabs brought with them
from India that's also where the game of
chess was invented so al andaluz was the
first European country where chess was
played
one of the city's famous residents was
the painter francisco de goya
born in 1746 near Zaragoza he lived in
the city during his youth the Museum of
Zaragoza is the only one in the world to
own a complete collection of Goya's
etchings works which testify to the
vividness of his imagination CBM which
has been the background is often made up
of a very dry landscape resembling the
ebro valley and you can almost feel the
wind that's so typical of our region
they being dogged I mean is muy typical
Zaragoza as historical center offers
plenty of tapas bars to choose from jose
robles has won several gourmet
competitions with his tapas the pmo here
we've got rabbit with vegetables liver
and black trumpet mushrooms then egg
with white truffles from the piedmont it
is like you've never done cod with olive
oil boiled potato and garlic mayonnaise
hello and then there's duck in red wine
with vegetables all classical cuisine
then it's a lot of work but that's what
it takes if you want to eat well
a trip to a tapas bar with friends is
the perfect end to a day in Zaragoza
lights camera action that's the order of
things on film sets all over the world
and when Berlin rolls out that red
carpet for its annual Film Festival well
parties tend to make up a lot of the
action now these are less about letting
your hair down and a lot more about
making important connections and
networking and if you do it right you
can be on your feet for days on end and
so we tagged along with one of this
year's movers and shakers over 400 films
are being screened during the Berlin
Film Festival and among them is one by
actor and director tom za mulatto it's
an exciting week for the 29 year old
social Nets the gunston Lord that it's
great to be here with the whole gang who
made the film some three months ago it
helps you stop feeling nervous and
reminds you how much fun it all is I'm
spanning done its man we got Indians
past summers downstairs is his
directorial debut and the filmmaker and
his crew are celebrating ahead of the
premiere
then it's curtain up the cinema is
packed to the rafters
a German French co-production zama
lattice film is a bittersweet comedy
about sibling rivalry
how do you say bathroom is free dash by
dat Zoomer East High hmm does bad azeema
is high the audience loved it if the
fledgling director is feeling the strain
he's not letting it show yeah as
regarded man cut it's been spooky gets
mine copper there are mixed emotions
it's a wonderful but it's very
overwhelming too soon I buzzes gotta zip
you at the after-show party he's able to
let his hair down with his family and
friends and rub shoulders with familiar
faces from the german film industry this
isn't a tues or destroyed the damn this
is the big night oh and if my voice is a
bit rough tomorrow and my eyes are a bit
droopy it doesn't matter this wasn't
just any old premiere after all it was
also the opening film of the young
German filmmakers section of the
festival but for all the thrills and
spills the festival is also a test of
endurance even for seasoned stars such
as christofides Christian Bale Natalie
Portman
Charlotte Rampling and Daniel blue
there's always another party to attend
for the festival's 20,000 industry
visitors every day is packed with
premieres press conferences and sponsors
receptions we're networking is the order
of the day after a sleepless night and a
number of interviews tom za mulatto is
still going strong time for a quick
breather and a quick coffee before the
next event it's rid of me for many style
umlauf women it would be nice to have
some interesting conversations but I'll
had speed on it but I'm not expecting to
go home with 20 deals in my pocket it's
one suspect being the house that again
he certainly had illustrious company at
this bash which was attended by til
schweiger vim vendors and udo kier it
was a who's who of German cinema the
event also sauce la mulata named as one
of the ten Europeans to watch in the
movie business the hosts Variety
magazine and a major german film funding
board but that's not the only reason
it's such a draw but I started
it's one of the main events at the film
festival a highlight does this it's
about ninety six percent fun that agenda
it's always nice to meet up with
colleagues and have a chat if at all
possible by the sous les did you see
Maurice close yeah this fear is great
but you have to make sure you stay awake
during the festival Baron de belem other
advice that tom za mulatto could do well
to heed it remains to be seen if this
year's festival marks his breakthrough
as a director
for the time being it's a whole week of
partying yeah the Berlin Film Festival a
chance for movers and shakers to
showcase their work but also to
celebrate
well it has been a long time since I
donned a pair of ice skates but our next
destination is the kind of place that
will make you want to divorce in eastern
Switzerland is famous as a host city of
the world economic forum but it's also a
very popular resort for winter sport
fans and it's not just the hills that
are the big attraction
welcome to Europe's largest natural ice
rink at the Swiss Winter Sports Resort
of divorce covering an area equivalent
to two and a half soccer fields it
offers training space for professionals
and those who want to be former ice
hockey player Martin hege was born and
bred here but only started speed skating
at 30 for the past 16 years he's trained
on the outdoor rink which is thought to
be one of the fastest in the world it's
astonished nailed of thing what makes it
fast is the film that builds up on the
ice and the Sun it's a layer of water
that allows for high speeds I session 80
so when it's sunny and the temperatures
rise and you picked the perfect moment
ciple could attend the ice here is as
good as the ice in any top indoor rink
recruiter sorry Nana told paula the
complex is 140 years old it owes its
international fame partly to the fact
that the National Ice Skating
Association of Great Britain had its
competitors train here and also because
the resort hosted more than 30 European
and world championships in speed skating
and figure skating in the summer it's
used for track and field it's a nice
ring for just two and a half months a
year it used to be full but climate
change has taken its toll and
professional athletes have moved on see
love in a nice holiday I'd rather use
indoor rinks because they know exactly
what they're getting izd secret idea
when you're outside you might find one
year that conditions aren't great and
you have to wait for the next season
that doesn't work in professional sports
housing provision that's only okay if
you're doing it for the sheer love of
the sport mine is an [ __ ] mock diamond
asleep
but some things haven't changed every
morning the snow is cleared off the ice
then it's sprayed with water fresh from
the Swiss Alps which then freezes in
divorce the art of ice making has been
handed down from generation to
generation since 1877 this is diver what
makes us experts is our many years of
experience we have to know how and
understand how temperature and timing
factors in as well as when the ice is
best left alone it's money unless my
loss I said Warren courses also take
place here anub arak her flesh teaches
figure skating twice a week including
practice in turning the perfect
pirouette
you
özkan slothful deciding on this figure
skating is a wonderful blend of art and
athletics it's a way of expressing
herself you can turn pirouettes you jump
integrate music there's just so much to
it and I think that's what explains its
appeal Thank You Dustin schwarze the
Faustini and lock her students have
already set their goals sad I want to be
Swiss champion and compete in the world
championships between mid-december and
late februari the ice rink draws around
15,000 amateur skaters you'll get
spectacular on top see weekly I feel
like I'm in heaven for locals such as
Claudio Meng ice skating is big business
he's not only president of the
International Skating Club in divorce he
also runs a family business that
specializes in sharpening skate blades
boss master kundo me teasing sleep I
have to know what sort of skating the
customer is going to be doing is he an
amateur or a competitor thighs and that
determines which blade is required
Ethan's baking on Austin the natural ice
rink is open for another month after
that anyone who still wants to enjoy
winter sports in divorce had better
exchange their skates will their skis
what a winter that is well finally it's
over to Germany's Rhineland now where
carnival or what the locals they are
called the fifth season is gathering
momentum as it heads into its final days
of festivities now all and sundry do get
into the carnival spirit over in Cologne
revelers musicians and of course all
those many dancers who add a good deal
of spice to all those carnival shindigs
and to see just how passionate they can
get about what they do then you just
need to meet biggie financial the
Cologne carnival dance troupe the lift
flutter stars at some of the biggest
celebrations in the Rhineland and the
female dancers in the group called the
mauritian set the festive mood
maybe three year old biggie fun and
schreiber is known as the mother of the
mauritian she's choreographed for them
for around half a century he explains
how she maintains her energy it comes
from dancing not carnival the event is
just a means to an end it gives us the
chance to show what we're made of
investment in on time no Alex laughs
lots of work goes into the routines
there are two or three rehearsals a week
in Kelowna looked floated answers are
famous for daring throws about 50
dancers try out each year but only a few
make the cut that most munch on you have
to be strict but you can't forget
they're amateurs they work and do this
in their free time so you can't just
yell at them or not you need to say
great you did that well but you can do
it better next time blasted it's why
you're mad I realized about that
consumer feel better during the season
they put on more than a hundred shows
sometimes need a day it's exhausting
work but the dancers are excited to be
able to participate I always watched
them when I was a girl and wanted to
dance to I really worship the funkin
rotation yeah I even saw the Luther
flutter back when I was a girl so I'm
thrilled to be living it now Thai food
that's leaving so do Fe biggie is always
coming up with new choreography often by
adapting moves from ballet many other
Cologne dance troupes have adopted her
lifts and throws ginger leg properly
okay bestie you can bring grandma down
now
borrowing from ballet did not happen by
chance until the late 1960s biggie
danced as a ballerina in Germany and in
the US after she had a child she left
classical ballet and became a carnival
dancer and then a dancing coach rich
brunette is coach I'm a real cologne
girl carnivals great went down and it
was nice for me because it's a wonderful
happy form of dance you should tan
Sardis or working with young people is
fun Pass deal of coaching them and then
seeing how you shape their dancing Lizzy
nah it's just fantastic ah dad I thought
that that's out now come to meet you
even though she's over 83 Miggy has not
lost a step she often develops new
choreography in her living room and turn
and snap the final pose carnival dance
troupes were invented in the Rhineland
the costumes are based on 18th century
military uniforms with an exaggerated
and humorous twist at the start the
mauritian were amends only role it was
only later that women got involved
but there are still troops with only men
and Big E also coaches one of them
men call themselves the dancing cream
puffs all very tongue-in-cheek been cada
vez Papa Dodds making fun of yourself is
what carnivals for what better way to do
it then to Donna 22 and take the stage
the name of that is avenues and without
the power D Mathis it's a way of life
and Big E has no plans to retire anytime
soon
I just can't stop I gotta dance dance
dance this is a local carnival club
meeting in Cologne about 500 guests are
here backstage the dancers are getting
fired up for the show coach biggie
wishes them luck and then they're off
all that hard work paid off even the
most difficult of throws goes smoothly
the dancers flies through the air and
their coach is thrilled to they still
have dozens of performances until the
season ends along the carnival on Ash
Wednesday and right after Easter
rehearsals will start again for next
year
dance dance dance obviously a good
recipe for keeping you young well don't
forget about our website or our Facebook
page where you can keep up with current
conversations going on about the program
and with that it is time for us to sign
off from this highlights edition so
until next time I'll school to phone on
Saul's billion and thanks for watching
just totally
you